Independence will tend to be in the
Forefront of favoring structural
political reform that levels the playing
field and and essentially
says look political parties can compete
in the political Marketplace but they
shouldn't also be running the
competition which is how it works right
now and so we need a non-partisan system
we need structural reforms and we need
the right to be an independent you
shouldn't have to join a political
organization in order to have your full
Democratic rights in the United States
of America it's that simple
foreign
[Music]
it is my pleasure to welcome to forward
the president of Independent voting the
co-director of the center for an
independent sustainable democracy at ASU
and board member of the forward party
Jackie saylet welcome Jackie thank you
Andrew great to be with you on
Thanksgiving week so you're the
co-author of this new book The
Independent voter with your co-director
Tom Riley and then also a history
Professor named Omar Ali I got a lot out
of this book how did this book come
about Tom and I had been writing
chapters in various volumes on the
independent voter and in discussion with
Omar Ali about the story that we were
trying to tell and the three of us
decided that this could be a moment
where writing a book that was dedicated
specifically to talking about who is the
independent voter what is this phenomena
about why are they so misunderstood in
the political world which they are and
so we decided to take a shot at it and
we reached out to a couple of Publishers
and Routledge press grabbed the project
right away and asked us to finish the
manuscript quickly which we did and now
we're out in print
now well congratulations on that so I
think of you as sort of the Godmother of
independent voters you're literally the
president of Independent voting in a org
for independent voters how the heck did
you wind up working on three
presidential campaigns I think you
worked on Bloomberg's campaign too like
you you you're sort of the uh Paragon of
Independence like how the heck did that
come about you know it's such an
interesting question and I think there
were so many cross currents some of them
were personal and some of them I guess
were you know more contextual but
uh you know I grew up in a very uh
politically aware and politically active
family we were involved in the Civil
Rights Movement we were involved in the
anti-vietnam war Movement we were
involved in the independence movement in
Africa I would periodically come home
from school and my mother would say oh
hi there's now three Nigerian students
who are living with us because they're
studying government and they're going to
go back and they're going to you know
govern their country kind of thing this
was a fairly common occurrence in my
house so I grew up uh in that kind of
environment and then I went to work for
a major television network
uh covering actually the two national
political conventions in Miami in 1972
and through that experience frankly I
just started to think uh hey you know
there's
there's something off track right now in
our political system I couldn't even
really exactly put my finger on it I
know you talk about this a lot when you
talk about your own decision to go ahead
and leave the Democratic party and found
the forward party it was a different
time then but still I felt that it was a
good moment to experiment with some
other forms of political activity so I
got involved in independent politics
really in the late 1970s
there were some important fights going
on inside the Democratic party in New
York at that time where black and Latino
elected officials and leaders were
trying to rise up in the electoral
process and in government and so forth
and they were being blocked by the party
bosses and so we entered into some
coalitions then that I was a part of uh
created something called the new
alliance party at the time and uh and a
significant number of local elected
officials who were basically looking to
leverage their position and punish
uh frankly the racism and the
paternalism of the local Democratic
Party by going independent and that's
kind of what got me into the game and
then all kinds of things happened from
there
yeah I learned a lot in your your book
uh the independent voter about the
presidential candidacy of a woman uh
Leonora Fulani uh who was apparently the
first black woman to be on the belt in
all 50 states which is a freaking feat
um and it seems like you were there
grinding away helping to make that
happen what what what was that campaign
about her first run was in 1988 and as
you say that was the year that she got
on the ballot in all 50 states and
became the first woman and the first
African-American in U.S history to do
that which was extraordinary in and of
itself her campaign was really uh it was
so appreciate Andrew was really about
raising the issue of the state of the
democratic process and the ways in which
the parties have a lockdown on uh the
parameters of policy on participation on
they make the rules and you know those
who make the rules I just want to
interject very quickly yeah
um I confess like I don't remember this
campaign at all and of course I was very
young in ad I was a teenager but I
remember Jesse Jackson
um and I and I do not remember fulani's
campaign even though fulani's campaign
in some ways made it further because she
was on on the ballot as an independent
well really a good point because uh of
course Jackson ran for the first time in
84.
he established that there was you know a
very powerful uh Insurgency inside the
Democratic party and uh and then that
came to not
you know and so in 88 when Dr philani
Ran her message was two rows are better
than one let's support Jackson in the
Democratic primary process because
Jackson was running for a second time at
that point and had a very very diverse
and Broad Coalition but Dr fulani's plan
was and our plan was uh if Jackson were
to fail to get the nomination or fail to
be put on the ticket then there'd be an
independent road that those voters could
get on and so that was really the
impetus of the campaign it was two roads
are better than one let's play inside
the Democratic party and go independent
on the outside so that campaign it you
know ruffled uh more than ruffled uh it
stepped on toes shall we say and you
know and honestly some of the response
that I see you getting you know
particularly from the liberal left in
terms of you know oh my God you can't go
independent or if you go independent it
means you're really a right winger and
all this kind of stuff well Dr philani
you know endured a lot of that going
back to the Early to the late 80s rather
in the early 90s her right winger seems
ridiculous
you know it was so revealing I'll tell
you you know in 1988 when we were just
launching the campaign I write about
this in the book uh one of the first
things that you have to do is register
with the Federal Election Commission of
course if you're you know raising money
and you have to file the name of a
committee so uh she filed the name of
her committee and it was called Lenora B
falani's committee for fair elections
and the Federal Election Commission said
to her you can't call the committee that
because what is fair elections have to
do with running for Bruce
so right away we were in a legal battle
with the FEC which as you well know is
made up of Democrats and Republicans
only
and uh we had to fight that we actually
won that fight uh but it was you know it
was such an education I'll tell you
because you just came up against those
baked in biases at every level of the
administration of the electoral process
against Independence and it was a real
learning experience uh and so you went
from there to the Perot campaign in the
last slight in the next cycle is that
right yeah what happened was that um
Lenora ran again in 1992.
and uh she actually started the campaign
running as a democrat in the Democratic
Primary in New Hampshire and going into
New Hampshire she had raised more money
than every other candidate other than
Paul Tsongas at the time so that
included Bill Clinton Doug Wilder Jerry
Brown a couple of other candidates I
think Tom Harkin and so forth so she had
like real a lot of popularity at the
Grassroots level and after the Dem
primary she moved to be an independent
and ran the rest of the campaign Pro ran
also that year for the first time and
during the course of the campaign she
recognized I think very smartly
um that Perot you know Perot was getting
a lot of coverage Perot was allowed into
the presidential debates Perot was
really driving the issue of uh running
as an independent independent voters
independent approaches all of that and
so her message shifted
at a certain point and basically what
she told the public was look I'm a black
woman I'm a progressive uh I've been out
there for a long time fighting in the
trenches now I'm running as an
independent if I'm too black if I'm too
much of a woman if I'm too radical for
you don't vote for me but vote for Ross
Perot vote for an independent use your
vote to make a statement about the
importance of creating something new for
the American people
so of course you know Pro uh got in got
out got it you know back in all that
kind of crazy stuff at one point he was
pulling at 42 percent of the vote uh but
in the end he got 20 million votes and
during the course of
that campaign Pro activists around the
country started to reach out to Dr
falani and ask her to come and speak it
you know the the
um the Perot campaign in Orange County
California which is one of the most
conservative districts in the country
asked her to come out and speak and she
did and she talked about the need to
bring people together and re-engineer
reimagine redesign our political process
and she got a huge response and so after
the campaign was over
uh I would say a network of parole
leaders at the state level reached out
to us to her and to us and said hey can
we sit down and talk and so
from that point on there was a coalition
between the Fulani movement and the
parole movement at the Grassroots to try
to generate a new National political
party and we formed something called The
Patriot party which was really designed
to push Perot and push the Perot
movement as a whole to go independent
and build a party not just be an
independent candidate but invest in
building a national infrastructure and
we succeeded in doing that so by 96 we
were building the national reform party
we had a national all-independence
primary
uh in which uh Perot and um former
Governor Colorado governor dick lamb uh
ran and pero Gap denomination and we ran
that campaign at that point as a party
building campaign
this show is sponsored by betterhelp
holiday season is around the corner and
even though Christmas and New Year's are
festive celebratory times for a lot of
us they're also really depressing times
for a lot of us it's easy to get anxious
or Lonesome or to question things I
first saw a therapist when I was a
teenager and have been a big believer
ever since and betterhelp is a fantastic
way to get the help you need as the
world's largest therapy service better
help has matched 3 million people and
Counting with professionally licensed
and vetted therapists available 100
online plus it's affordable just fill
out a brief questionnaire to match with
a therapist and if things aren't
clicking you can easily switch to a new
therapist anytime it couldn't be simpler
no waiting rooms no traffic no endless
searching for the right therapist learn
more and save 10 percent off your first
month at betterhelp.com Yang that's
betterhelp
h-e-l-p.com slash yang
[Music]
wow so the the 96 Pro campaign I
confessed to not having as clear a
recollection of
um you know in 92 we got 19 I remember
him in the debates uh what happened in
96
in 96 he got eight and a half percent
which set in motion of course as you
know a lot of states have you know a
benchmark of a number of votes that you
have to acquire
uh generally speaking in a presidential
race or in a gubernatorial race is often
the case and that establishes a ballot
status party
so by the time we came out of the 96
campaign with eight and a half percent
of the vote we had ballot lines in 30
States and that was huge yeah and uh
then you know we began to Embark upon
the process of what it meant to actually
build all of those State party
organizations
to keep it as a unified National party
but the platform of the party was very
different than what a typical party
platform is and you know that well
because you've been developing that also
for forward but it was really focused on
uh political reform and fiscal reform
and then we set up a series of task
forces to engage certain kind of hot hot
button issues like the immigration
question and I was the chair of the
immigration uh wow project and you know
everyone said oh my God this thing is
going to be a bloodbath because you know
have people on the right the Perot
movement was very engaged and agitated
over immigration policy and the Fulani
movement as well arguably on different
sides of the fence uh we all sat in a
room together and it turned out that
there was so much Common Ground there
and we hammered out you know it wasn't
exactly a platform but really kind of
maybe a set of values and ways that we
thought that Congress needed to proceed
in order to deal with the issue and of
course ultimately when the matter
you know got into the hands of Congress
they couldn't do anything with it or
maybe more accurately they wouldn't do
anything with it because as you're very
fond of pointing out now and it's
chilling
um politicians do better when they don't
solve problems than when they do solve
problems because then they can sort of
just keep hammering on the issue and
that the other side didn't come in and
do what they were supposed to do and
blah blah blah blah but the fact of the
matter is is that if you take all of
that junk and partisanship out of the
process and you just put people to work
on the issues there's a lot of progress
that can be made
well so 96 you're on the ballot in 30
States uh you are putting together this
policy platform what happened to the
Reform Party because now people are
looking up being like where the heck did
uh um that did those uh 30 State
chapters go yeah
I'll tell you a good question I can tell
you my narrative on it from where I sat
um a couple of things happened first of
all when when Dick lamb came in and ran
in the primary in 96 he obviously had
come from the Democratic party and he
ran a campaign which he lost he refused
to endorse Perot and this kind of set a
tone I would say within the party where
there was a lot of fractiousness and
also kind of a wing of the democratic
party which then began to try to attack
the Reform Party to challenge its
credibility to challenge the process by
which it was being built and so that you
know kind of weakened the situation a
little bit then in 98 Jesse Ventura ran
for governor in Minnesota on the Reform
Party affiliate line there he won that
election which was extraordinary but
then Jesse who you know I think you know
was you know did a lot of really good
things and and really brought forth the
issue of independent politics and also
he won a governorship as an independent
but there was also a lot of friction
between him and between the Perot group
kind of a power struggle that went on
uh that never really fully got resolved
and then
uh
uh pero's running mate in 1996 was Pat
show Dr Pat showed who was a caught an
economist who was one of the very first
people to ring the bell very loudly
about the negative impact of
globalization on American manufacturing
and jobs
and and he and I became very uh close I
would say and and very connected and
uh he called me one day and he said Pat
Buchanan is a friend of mine the
conservative commentator of course Pat
had just come out of the Iowa straw poll
and he did very poorly
and he and Pat were very close Pat
showed and Pat called me and he said Pat
Buchanan is thinking of leaving the
Republican party and coming to seek the
Reform Party nomination in 2000. are you
open to that and would you consider that
I said well if Pat Buchanan is coming in
and will support the principles of the
party and back burner his social
conservative agenda and stand up with us
for political reform and fiscal reform
then that's something that we would
consider we had lunch with Pat
Buchanan at the Essex House it was all
very hush-hush the meeting we did it at
the Essex House on Central Park uh South
in New York and Pat and his sister flew
on separate planes from Washington
because they didn't want to run into any
reporters and anybody see them and blah
blah blah blah anyway we had the meeting
we had the conversation we said this to
Buchanan he said I'm down I can do it
I'll I'll go with you on the reform
front I'll back burner everything else
etc etc
um and we said okay well you know
private conversation let us you know
kind of digest this and whatnot and then
he went on CNN that night and he told
the story of the me the meeting so I was
like well okay that's so much for the
you know the secret off the Record
Maybe
um but
uh we
uh a coalition and I will tell you it in
the early days of it Andrew it was
incredibly exciting because here was a
very prominent right-winger
and a well-known and popular
Progressive a left-winger who was also
African-American and a woman
and we put together a coalition and said
hey we're going to put our ideological
differences wow blackburner and we're
going to focus on these structural
reforms and reconstituting American
democracy in a more fair and
inclusionary manner
and that went well for about three
months
um and then
Pat Buchanan basically abrogated the
deal
and though I'm not privy to the
information of exactly what happened I
can tell you that I believe that the
Republican party and Republican
leadership
leaned on him like nobody's business I
mean the media went crazy in response to
the Coalition on the left and on the
right
uh and we were you know the incoming was
from all sides you know it was kind of
like you didn't know where to look and
there was nowhere to hide kind of thing
but it was good because it really
brought these issues out to the fore and
I can tell you that Lenora
got so many letters from people who were
part of Pat Buchanan's base saying you
know I I I'm so glad that we're working
together I'm so glad that we're building
these Bridges you know and and all of
that
um but basically Pat abrogated the deal
he started to run what was essentially a
takeover operation inside of the Reform
Party
he took we had because of the strength
of the showing in 1996 we had qualified
for 18 million dollars and general
election matching funds
um he grabbed the money
uh he grabbed the nomination there was a
split convention he grabbed the
nomination the courts upheld his claim
uh which was somewhat speechless frankly
um he took the money and he ran a very
very poor campaign and for all intents
and purposes that was the end of their
foreign party
you know one thing I'm thankful for I
wrote a book it's called Ford and it's
now out on paperback I promise you it is
not as boring as a book with democracy
and the title sounds like it's got fun
stories from the presidential will make
you think it'll make you laugh and you
can check it out on paperback or get it
for a friend Happy Holidays Ford now out
on paperback
[Music]
foreign
so you talked about the 18 million in
matching funds the Reform Party got
because Perot had done well in the prior
election uh the threshold is five
percent if your Party candidate gets
over five percent in the national
election then your party receives
matching funds in the next cycle which
now I think would be closer to 30
million dollars and there is a minor
party that I shall leave nameless that
asked me to run on their ticket because
they thought I'd get them over five
percent and they were just in for the
money they just wanted a 30 million next
time
so uh that it's something that a lot of
people aren't aware of but the Reform
Party was one of the very few parties
that actually beat that threshold and
got matching funds in real life exactly
and there are also there is a what they
call a primary matching funds program
where uh a candidate has to raise a
certain amount of money spread out over
I think it's 20 states with
contributions from different
congressional districts it's a pretty
onerous requirement
Dr Fulani got matching Federal primary
matching funds in 1988 and I think she
got close to a million dollars in
primary matching funds which meant she
had to have raised a million and then
she spent the entire match on ballot
access and on the cost of getting on the
ballot oh that's actually helpful
because I was wondering how she pulled
that trick yeah there was a point when I
was running for president that someone
showed me the uh requirements and I
actually did pass them by the way like
yeah like like we were looking at the
matching funds now no major candidate
uses the matching funds because it it
restricts how much money you can spend
so it also marks you as uncompetitive
yeah but but when I looked at it it was
actually a pretty good value like I you
know like I could have gotten millions
of dollars in free money it just would
have capped My overall spend at I think
no exactly that's the trade-off and so
the major candidate the major party
candidates don't use it anymore uh and
there's also there's also Congress has
looked at the question of abolishing it
all together and in the Klobuchar
mansion
compromise version of the Democracy bill
that the Democrats put together they
abolished they would have abolished the
federal primary matching funds program
now their their legislation did not move
forward but um but it was on the table
and it was in the bill so you know this
stuff is all on the chopping block now
yeah it seems a little bit anachronistic
but I did look at it and I thought like
oh maybe I should take advantage of this
um because even if you run within a
Democratic primary uh you could qualify
for the money yes exactly and so I
looked at it I mean happily thank you
Yang Yang like we got to a point where
it uh would have not been a net Win For
Us
in terms of sure our competitiveness but
if we had been below where we were like
uh you know my campaign raised 40
million and that was high enough so that
we could spend more in the early States
than the the cap but if we'd been at
something like the 10 million dollar
range then the matching funds probably
would have been a net win for us I think
we would have gotten another
um you know maybe like eight to ten
million dollars in matching money so
there's a there's by the way there's a
an equation you can draw it out but like
yeah
below which like the
matching funds are a win any
enterprising future presidential
candidates out there you can check it
out and take advantage of the system
while it's still there
all right
so and so you are in many ways
like the guide to all of independent
political movements over the last uh uh
40 or 50 years so you went from there to
Bloomberg is that right we did we did
and that was is really cool we had uh we
had established a ballot Line in New
York so even after the Reform Party
imploded we still have the state party
and so
uh beginning in 2000 uh we cross endorse
and New York by the way also is what we
call a fusion State I know you're
familiar with that uh that practice only
eight states allow for fusion and
there's yeah it's too bad Fusion voting
is great it's excellent and there's a
terrible Supreme Court decision on the
fusion uh question which came down in
the late 90s Fusion voting is something
that's in effect in eight states it's
very positive what it means is that if
you are a minor party you get your own
line uh the the next time which is
massively advantageous because then you
can actually endorse candidates and your
endorsement is Meaningful by the way
Connecticut is a fusion voting State and
that's how the forward party affiliate
in Connecticut managed to get the
governor to endorse running Choice
voting because in order to get that line
which the Consultants estimated was
worth three percent uh they said hey got
indoors wearing Choice voting um now
unfortunately the other states have
realized that this is good for minor
parties and been going around uh getting
rid of it is that all a fair description
it is I mean the basic
basis that a candidate can run on more
than one party line and their lot and
their votes those votes are aggregated
and the voter can choose which line they
want to cast to vote for the candidate
on and uh what that does is it gives as
you're saying it gives leverage to uh
minor parties and allows them to enter
into and to play Within and interact
within the political mainstream in ways
that are much more powerful than just
being a third party that gets two
percent of the vote and gets to make a
point about an issue but doesn't really
have an impact but in any event Mike was
going to run for mayor
we had cross endorsed some Republicans
for local office and so the Republican
party was kind of like oh hey you know
what's this you know maybe we can use
this to get support from Independence
and Mike had as you know Mike had been a
Democrat but he knew he could not get
through a Democratic primary so he
re-registered as a Republican and pretty
much got a pledge from the Republican
party that he would have the Republican
line however Mike both wanted a way to
engage with independent voters and also
he was an independent
uh and he also needed a line where
Democrats could vote for him without
pulling a republican lever and so he
reached out to us and we had a series of
meetings uh with him about the campaign
and he made a very simple pledge to us
which was that if he were elected mayor
uh if we endorsed him and gave him the
line and if you were elected mayor he
would lead the charge to bring
non-partisan open primaries to New York
City and we said deal absolutely and he
said actually he said smart businessman
that he is he said now are you sure you
want to make this deal because if we
pass nonpartisan elections it's
basically going to put you out of
business
and we said Yes actually the whole point
of this party is to put ourselves out of
business we want a nonpartisan process
not one that's based on parties and yes
we would love for that to be the case so
we made the deal
he ran
of course 9 11 happened on primary day
uh so you know the whole political
environment was very upended but the
outcome was that he won the election by
35 000 votes which was an incredibly
narrow margin and he got 60 000 votes on
the independence party ticket so
basically we were his margin of Victory
and the independence were his margin of
Victory and that
set up what became a 12-year partnership
with Mike because we endorsed him into
successive elections
and he kept that promise he and paneled
a charter revision commission he
actually panel two commissions because
the first one didn't put it on the
ballot the second one
did it went to the ballot and we lost uh
70 30. but the key thing Andrew to know
is that every political party other than
the independence party every Club has
every newspaper an editorial board
except for the Daily News
every Union
and all but one or two elected officials
opposed the initiative the New York
Times editorial board editorialized
against it viciously as did the New York
Post
so
frankly the fact that we got 30 percent
of the vote which I as I recall was
something like I don't know 140 000
votes or something was also an off-year
election it was just very the whole
thing was very challenging but the
entire political establishment came down
on us and just tried to crush this thing
and you know they had we were able to
put I think maybe six or seven hundred
volunteers out at the polls with you
know vote Yes on I think it was question
three
um wow yes on question three that seems
familiar go ahead continue exactly no
exactly
um but the unions put thousands
thousands
of people out at the polls with vote no
messaging and uh you know and we just
weren't strong enough to withstand it
and and the funny thing is that all the
newspapers after the election tried to
blame Mike and said oh you know Mike is
really weak and he's you know Bubba
because they were still very against him
even though he was an excellent mayor
um he just wasn't part of the club and
they were like you know this Show's Mike
is weak and blah blah blah and so then I
called all the reporters and I said it
wasn't Mike's fault it was our fault it
was the Independence party's fault we
just simply weren't strong enough to
carry the day
there are a lot of uh battle wounds from
trying to open up the the system so you
did all of this work as an independent
political activist now you're the
co-director of this new center for an
independent sustainable democracy uh at
ASU and in many ways you're trying to
make the independent voter or political
Independence a real thing in terms of uh
academic study journalism
Etc so here are like the obvious
questions that people could ask
who the heck are independent voters like
what are they you know how many are they
are they real et cetera et cetera yeah
yeah well
well according to the gallon of polling
Gallup polling organization NP research
40 to 50 percent of Americans the number
fluctuates you know month to month uh
but between 40 and 50 of Americans
identify themselves as independents
and uh that is huge now uh those numbers
have been growing and its reach has been
growing so you know it's now the case
that I think it's 51 or 52 percent of
Millennials and gen Z identify as
Independence 40 of Iraq and Afghanistan
War veterans identify as Independents uh
depending on the state of where you are
like in Arizona for example 41 of
Latinos identify as Independents
um and uh something like 32 33 percent
of African Americans below the age of 30
identify as independent so it just kind
of cuts across generational lines racial
lines Geographic lines and so forth now
you know for 50 years or more
political science within the academy has
had a methodology for examining the
independent voter and for voter
identification overall and their
methodology is their first question when
they survey is they ask people how they
identify Democrat Republican or
independent if you say democrat or
republican they take it at face value
but if you say you're an independent
there's a follow-up question asked only
to people who identify as Independence
and the follow-up question is something
like
well which party do you identify with or
which party are you planning to vote for
in this cycle or which party did you
vote for in the last cycle or which
towards which philosophy do you lean
Democrat or Republican
so then people for the most part answer
that question
and then political science uses that
information to determine that you're not
really an independent that you're really
what they call a leaner or a shadow
partisan and consequently rather than
accepting
the numbers that are based on actual
polling and which people say who they
are and how they identify themselves
uh they re-define you based on the
answer to the second question and they
come up with a statistic that says well
there's really only between seven and
ten percent
of Americans are quote unquote what they
call true Independence and you know and
on the one hand you could say well you
know that's just Academia that's the
Ivory Tower but the fact of the matter
is is that and I'm not an academic but I
I do see the influence
that Academia has and that political
science has it just spills out into the
polling Community the politician
Community the media community and so
through this methodological sleight of
hand which essentially denies the thing
that the person just said to you you
know 30 seconds before
uh this community of Americans has been
written off or essentially channeled
into being partisans
but the fact of the matter is Andrew
that and I think you know this from your
personal experience and also just from
traveling around the country and talking
to people if you identify as an
independent that has meaning you are
saying something by doing that now what
are you saying well I've done a lot of
surveying and polling of that issue of
focused groups and but just talking to
people because as the president of
Independent voting that's what we do
um Independents are making a statement
of I would call it a statement of
non-compliance with the dominant culture
they've they've said they're an
independent for a reason because they
don't want to have to shoehorn
themselves into a partisan or an
ideological category they'll often tell
you they want to vote for the person not
the party
and that is Meaningful to people and
moreover we have found and I think this
is important given what's coming around
the bend now in the country is that
Independence will tend to be in the
Forefront of favoring structural
political reform that levels the playing
field and and essentially
says look political parties can compete
in the political Marketplace but they
shouldn't also be running the
competition which is how it works right
now and so we need a non-partisan system
we need structural reforms and we need
the right to be an independent you
shouldn't have to join a political
organization in order to have your full
Democratic rights in the United States
of America it's that simple
so at the center for an independent and
sustainable democracy at ASU we're
trying to comment that issue we're
trying to poke holes in the methodology
that's been used we're trying to elevate
the interaction and and the analysis of
independent voters and we're finding
that the volatility among Independents
the refusal to be categorized uh you
know people move in and out of
independent status they vote for
Democrats one cycle they vote for
republicans and other Cycles
uh you know independent supported Barack
Obama in very significant numbers in
2008 then they swung for Trump by four
points in 2016 and then they went for
Biden by 13 points uh in 2020. so you
know this is a community of Voters which
is very very hard to categorize and we
should stop trying to use the old
categories to understand them and create
a new framework for engaging with them
yeah you said a couple of things in the
book where I was like wow you put it
that way it's pretty hard to argue so
number one apparently the United States
is the only democracy where election
officials belong to one party or another
which makes a lot of sense that other
places are too smart for that because it
wouldn't make sense to have someone
wearing a party Jersey controlling
elections as a the district writer or
the Secretary of State or whatever the
heck it is
um so that's number one number two was
uh you should not be using taxpayer
money to fund party primaries if you're
not allowed to vote in them
because Independence yeah pay taxes so
it's like wait a minute why are you
spending money on some primary that like
I don't get to participate in well look
I mean those are two really important
points and you know as you say we we
talk about them we write about them a
lot in the book
um I it's really that we have these
practices uh is really an example of the
ways in which the parties have managed
to conflate themselves with the
government and but they're not the
government they're political parties
and they're you know they should be you
know they're they're protected by the
First Amendment and that's proper you
know and they can be uh political
associations of like-minded or
semi-like-minded people and they can
engage in all those different activities
but secretaries of State should not be
partisans the highest election officials
you know in any given jurisdiction
should not be partisans and taxpayers
should not be funding the activities of
private organizations that invoke their
right as private organizations to
exclude people from participating in the
electoral process so that's all the
stuff that needs to be fixed it's really
not that complicated it makes a lot of
sense and I think part of what's
happening in the country you know going
back to some of the history we've been
talking about when Perot was raising
these issues when Fulani was raising
these issues the question of democracy
and the structure and design of it was
considered an outlier issue
that's not the case anymore the the
question of how we run our elections and
who gets to decide on how the votes are
counted and all of that the peaceful
transition of power that's all center
stage in our country right now and you
know frankly you know we should have
taken care of these issues 25 years ago
but we didn't uh and now we do oh yeah
now we can sense that we're in danger of
losing our legitimacy to our own people
of slipping into authoritarianism or
autocracy or some version of it because
in a two-party system if you have one
bad leader uh then everyone in that
party falls behind that leader because
it's better them than the enemy which is
the other side polarization is so
extreme
um so they should have been taken care
of uh 30 years ago and the problems
frankly weren't quite as nasty as they
are now
foreign
the book which I found fascinating it's
like so what's keeping this in place is
like a whole set of pressures
um that are enforced by the media that
are enforced by various actors uh where
they really try and shunt away any
discussion of the two-party system and I
was like wow I mean you're such a
fascinating figure to me because you've
been engaged in the struggle for years
and years and years and years and then
Along Comes I'm going to call myself
something of like the new kid on the
Block like Andrew Young's like hey like
two-party system messed up which by the
way I didn't really get into the guts of
until 2020 when I I wrote forward and I
was like oh now I get it like we're
living through this terrible design flaw
that that that
uh is just going to get worse uh so
given everything that you've seen and
been through with the Reform Party in
particular uh when forward came along
first you've been awesome and generous
and like and uh an incredible asset and
Champion
um from the beginning uh but like how
the heck are we going to to uh succeed
where this other movement that was at
least at one point funded by a
billionaire or another Point had like
these bookending conservative and uh
black women Progressive uh leaders like
how are we going to succeed where they
failed I do think the climate is much
better for us now than it was then in
some ways uh you know like me that like
the the trust in like the media that
call it straight is like much lower now
than it might have been then there are
so many different ways to get
information of the number of people who
identify as Independence might be twice
as high now as it was then you know I
think that said well first of all I
thank you so much for your kind words
here I am
I think there's a there's a certain
leadership quality uh that you bring to
the table and others in in the forward
party do but I I so for example you and
I we we went to Chicago
a couple months ago and we met with a
group of black ministers and and
Community leaders there all of whom have
you know or most of whom have been very
attached to the Democratic party you
know in Chicago as is the case for the
bulk of the black community and we sat
in one of The Minister's studies at his
church on the west side and we spent
three hours talking and I saw you
be able to respond to their questions
and and their concerns and the realities
of you know what they're dealing with
um with their congregations and with the
poverty on the west side and you know
the Democratic party politicians blow in
and out of their churches and I saw you
talk to them about how you saw these
issues and the extent to which that if
their association with forward meant
that the Democratic party showed up and
said hey yeah okay we've been ignoring
you but now we're going to pay more
attention and we're going to bring some
more stuff into your community
um but you have to you have to stay with
Democrats in order to do that
um you said well you know if that
happens then I consider forward a
success
because you used us for leverage yeah
that's true to get something good for
the communities that you represent and
if that doesn't happen and if we're able
to grow and become an independent force
and you're associated with that then all
good too and and so I've seen you do
that and I've seen you and that's a very
particular kind of conversation to have
you you have a certain you're very
honest with people you don't try to sell
them a bill of goods but you actually do
talk to them about the political
leverage that can be acquired by being
independent and you know you and I were
just in I I live in Arizona now but you
came to Phoenix and we you know met with
some
political people there and they some of
them said to you well what's the
relationship between all of these
reforms that are necessary and building
the Reform Party because they might seem
like they're opposites and you said
well we're building this party in order
to use it as a leverage tool in order to
accomplish these structural political
reforms because that's what we think
needs to happen now and that's the most
important thing to do so one thing I
want to run by you I think I mentioned
it too when we were in Arizona together
but one big idea that I have for 2024 is
we get a bunch of Independents together
in Arizona Nevada Georgia Michigan
Pennsylvania Wisconsin the six swing
states that are almost certainly going
to decide the 2024 race
and the margins are very narrow less
than one percent in three or four of
these states and what we do is we get a
list of let's call it you know several
hundred thousand independent voters and
say hey we're genuine swing voters uh we
can vote either way and we're going to
back whichever candidate or party
supports various reform measures and
then we enumerate them and say like if
you do these things will come your way
what do you think my bright idea for the
title so far is five percent in six
swing States or five and six for short
what do you think I love it and I think
I think one thing it uses the fusion
strategy
without having to only be in a state
that allows fusion and I I think that's
very creative you know and going back a
number of years we used a similar
strategy that we called the chip process
choosing an independent president and we
we did the very thing that you're
describing kind of at a I would say on a
smaller scale and also the country was
less divided and the way that it is
today but look
leveraging the power of the independent
voter is crucial right now this is what
is going to develop and mature the
electorate and and that needs to happen
so I love that idea and I will tell you
you know I have networks of independent
voters in all of those States and yeah
you're the president of Independent
voting that's what I'm talking about
independentvoting.org right
yeah yeah so uh in the book you talk
about the three things that Independence
uh can do number one they're the change
makers because then they push in a
direction then uh the parties have to
respond number two they can get behind
these reforms to move us to uh
non-ideological post-partisan reality
which is what forward uh is is fighting
for uh and then the the third thing we
can do is we can actually swing races in
in various ways uh and thinking about
independence in those those ways really
felt quite empowering
[Laughter]
and this five and six plan in a way it
demonstrates just how absurd our current
system is that a couple hundred thousand
voters who just happen to be in in
Arizona Nevada Georgia
like essentially control everything you
know like 44 of the states are
irrelevant it's just these six and it's
just like the sliver of people
um but I I loved your expression of what
independent voters both have done uh and
hopefully can do in the future yeah I
you know and we saw look we saw a lot of
that in in the midterm elections I mean
Independents were 31 of the electorate
nationally I think that's the biggest
National number that we've seen maybe
ever uh but certainly in 20 or 30 years
um in Arizona they were 40 percent of
the electorate and independents you know
delivered the senate race for Kelly
delivered the governorship to Katie
Hobbs uh delivered the secretary of
state election to uh Adrian Fontes so a
huge powerful force in Arizona but let
me just say the the Democratic party
should not assume that that means that
Independents are now Democrats that's
something that the parties tend to do at
the end of every cycle they are not they
made a choice in a particular historical
context as you were saying that's that's
what you've got to focus on it was also
true in Nevada uh it was true uh in the
senate race in Georgia thus far I think
Warnock
had an 11 or 12 point margin among
independent voters over Walker and
Independence broke for the Republican
for governor so there's just you know
there's a lot of volatility a lot of
differentials based on what's happening
in a given State and what's happening in
the country overall I think it would be
very fair to say and the evidence shows
this that Independence saved our
democracy in this election but it's
really just a holding action that's all
it is and that's why I think you know
what you're doing with the forward party
and I'm happy to be a part of it what
all of the leaders of the forward party
and all of you know the the forward
Leadership Council and the folks who are
signing on to the website and all of
that that is a force that can I believe
make a huge leadership uh difference for
the country in the next five to ten
years yeah you know my wife said
something which I I thought hit pretty
close to home it was like living on the
edge is not a strategy so someone
someone else said yes like like dodging
a bullet like it is not necessarily a
strategy uh you know when I was in
Arizona with you I said hey thank you
for helping us Dodge a carry Lakeside
bullet how many of you are confident we
can keep dodging that bullet here in Oz
Arizona for the next two four six eight
years and like now the single hand went
up you know I mean what was the market
like 20 000 votes I mean everyone knows
it was like you know like if we could
buy the
um you know the barest of margins uh and
some of the folks that we met with uh
you and I in Arizona are now excited
about about initiative uh that's very
much like Nevada's that would shift to
nonpartisan primaries and ranchers
running which I see now that's a
sustainable strategy it's like you look
up and you say Okay Carrie Lake almost
became governor of this thing uh despite
being you know like a like an election
denier and uh a demagogue in my mind
pretty clearly
um so you know if you change the process
then you have a a way out of this I
think Arizona is going to be one of the
ground zeros for democracy over the next
two years and by the way it's going to
be one of these six-wing states I'm
talking about
um though the forward obviously is a lot
to do before then
um but uh you know like I think there's
a lot we can do in in Arizona so after
everything you've seen and done are you
um more optimistic about our ability to
achieve these reforms uh like relative
to what has gone before uh like yeah
like where do you think we are give us
like a bit of historical perspective to
close us out and then let people know
where they can keep up with you and your
work
sure
um look I think it's going to be a tug
of war process I don't think it's going
to be a linear straight road I mean look
there's already talk in Alaska
that the legislature might take it upon
itself to repeal uh you know the Open
primary ranked Choice voting piece that
was passed there in Nevada as you say
state law requires for a citizen
initiative to be enacted it's got to
pass twice and the party's kind of laid
low in Nevada on this last go-round they
are going to come out full force in
2024. you know as you say there's going
to be an effort here in my state in
Arizona to go to ballot there's going to
be a lot of resistance unless frankly I
think one of the things that's
interesting to me about Arizona is that
because the Democratic party was such
the beneficiary of the independent voter
they really need to wise up and stop
acting like the independent voter
doesn't really exist they need to
make moves and accept overtures to
create a significant Coalition here that
recognizes and respects the sovereignty
of the independent voter and creates a
partnership around a political reform
agenda so but I think that we could be
talking about a situation where we're
going to take some losses you know in 24
because there's going to be blowback and
it's going to be powerful and it could
succeed so but I don't worry about that
honestly in one way because I think
we'll put up a fight and the more the
public comes to understand what's at
stake the more the public is engaged and
involved and the more there are places
like the forward party or independent
voting and people can go to our website
independentvoting.org to get more
information we do wonderful programs
including spokesperson training programs
to help Independents be able to tell
their story about why they decided to
become an independent then you know or
connect with us at ASU
um I think we're I think our movement is
going to grow whether we Face setbacks
in terms of you know the uh the uh
enactment of some of these reforms I
think we have to be prepared for it but
we will continue to go forward and I
think the overall environment and the
overall historical circumstances favor
our cause fantastic well more and more
Americans are waking up to the fact that
this is not sustainable this is not
working uh and you are someone I learned
a lot from uh and uh I've been fighting
for really the American people for a
long long time so thank you so much
Jackie Independence unite let that be
the message for all the ticked off
Americans out there who want something
better uh in our leadership I love it I
love it I love the message and um yep
Independence are real that could be the
subtitle
congratulations on this as well thank
you thanks for having me Andrew great
talking to you